Bộ nội vụ vừa có văn bản hướng giấn các địa phương thực hiện che đậu chính sách theo nghị định
một chăm mấy mấy tám và nghị định sau mấy mấy đối với cán mộ.
Công chức, viên chức, người là động thuộc diện sắp sẽ tổ chức bộ máy.
Trong đó, ở trong giải quyết chính sách cho bộ nhau đối tượng gồm, người còn dưới năm năm đến tuổi nghị hư,
người không đáp ứng yêu cầu hiểm vụ.
Nguyên chưa đặt trận trình đậu theo vị trí việc làm, người có su quay không bảo đam, anh ở ứng đến thực hiện chức chắc.
Các trường hợp con lại, đặc biệt là cán mộ, con chức còn từ 15 trở lên đến tuổi nghị hư, con năng lực, thành tích sẽ được yêu thiên giữ lại làm việc trong bộ máy mấy.
Bộ nội vụ khẳng định sẽ bảo đam đầy đủ quy lợi hợp pháp cho những người nghị việc đúng quy định,
đong thời yêu cầu các địa phương giải quyết kì thời hồ sơ, chủ đậu bộ chi kinh phía chi trả trở cấp.
Tình đến ngày 8,5 tằng sau, cán nước đã có hơn bộ mi ba nghìn hai trong người nghị việc theo dễ sắp tổ chức bộ máy.
Trong đó, hơn 2.5 tằng sau trong người đã được nhận hỗ trợ với tổng kinh phía gần 2.5 tình đồng.
Trong tháng 20, bộ nội vụ sẽ hoàn thiện phương án đường trình biệt lương và phụ cấp để chính các cấp có thẩm quyền trong tháng 3 tới,
nhằm đồng viên giữ chân đợi vụ cán mộ, con chức trong bộ máy hành trình mới.